thank you for
talking to me about what seems like it
was probably a very fun character to get
to explore
yeah oh she was a blast i'm curious when
the opportunity to play
one of these nine perfect strangers came
your way what was it that got you most
interested about the project since there
are
so many interesting so many things
there's so many things i got excited
about
um probably selfishly was that it was
filming in australia and
you know in this pandemic it's so hard
to get in and out of that country and
um i jumped at the opportunity to be
able to go there and
um see my family and friends over there
because
it's kind of impossible now yeah i mean
while you were shooting this did it sort
of feel like you were in your own little
world
totally it was really surreal it
kind of feels like a dream now because
it was like a year and a bit ago
um you know we were in this
like in paradise in the middle of it
felt really strange it was like we
what if i this doesn't we should be in
lockdown but
um you know australia did such a great
job of containing
everything that everything was open and
we could hang out and
you know we were by the beach and we
would just either be at this wellness
retreat or we'd be
in a waterfall or something it was it
was ridiculous
how involved was the process of creating
the look for your character how and how
much did that help you in finding who
she was
so much i mean the hair makeup
department and the wardrobe department
as well did
the real heavy lifting you know um we
would email back and forth about
different looks we wanted and
different outfits and um the yeah
when we did the makeup test
um that was when i really felt
uh jessica sort of come to life
ethan
there's some wild stuff that happens in
this show
and um one of those things is
and obviously i'll save it till after
it's a spoiler but it's having your nose
fall off
what was that like to do it was
i was so nervous because i think it was
like the
second or third scene i had done with
nicole
and i was like i guess i'm just gonna
have to go
for it and then she's gonna come in
um but they didn't use any uh makeup
which is cool they just had like cgi so
they just had dots on my face and then
this like funny prop
just my nose um i was practicing at home
in the mirror
well with my with my partner of like
okay is this a funny scream like should
i drop it like this
should i you know how would i what's the
truth behind this
um it was really fun i would also
imagine that you
could never have pictured yourself in a
delivery scene with
luke evans delivering bobby cannavale's
baby
so what goes to your head when you're in
a moment like that
just trying not to laugh they committed
to it
because that's what made it so funny and
so weird
and it just made me laugh and i just had
to buy my tongue
one of the sequences that i most enjoyed
was the potato sack race because
everybody actually seems to be having so
much fun in it
what was that like to shoot and how long
did you have to spend doing that
if i remember correctly i think we did
it in a day or maybe two
days mixed with some other scenes but it
was so fun i mean the sun was out and
beautiful green grass and we were all
just getting really into it i loved when
um
they used a slo-mo camera and we could
re-watch everyone's slo-mo face it was
that was fun if you're gonna get screwed
around with by anyone it seems like
nicole kidman
is a good choice to be doing that to you
so
what did you most enjoy about exploring
that dynamic between your characters and
having someone like her
as a scene partner especially with some
of the craziness that goes on
yeah i mean she's such a generous actor
she really gives you space to play
and find the scene and um
she's so patient it was amazing um
yeah she's she's just a wonderful and
you know she was a producer and so she
was a fabulous leader as well her and
melissa you know and all the women who
were producing this i mean bruno and
molly and
uh it was awesome what was your reaction
to the ending of the series learning
where things would
be left and how your character would end
up
yeah we actually didn't get the final um
episode script until like i think three
months into shooting or maybe longer
and it was really cool to like read
where your character is going to end up
in real time we'd kind of heard rumors
and we were wondering about it like
melvin and i would talk about
i wonder where ben and jessica end up
and is it going to be like the book or
is it going to be different and
it was awesome what was the most
challenging part of this shoot was there
a scene or a moment that was most
difficult because you do also have a lot
of emotional levels that you go through
yeah i mean honestly the most
challenging part i think was like
the amount of fake tans i'd have to go
and get getting my nails really done and
like getting my hair redone
i just cannot i have such admiration for
women who
do that on a weekly basis i do not have
the patience for it so
that was that was the most those nails
they were like
three inches long trying to do stuff
that's really hard
it's very impressive anybody that can
pull off the nails just in everyday life
lava what was it like to see yourself
with the tan
i mean especially the first time because
it seems like it's
you know it's quite noticeable yeah i
mean
if i stay in the sun long enough i can
get pretty dark i just i'm too lazy to
like lie out and you know in australia
there's such um
you know uh you can get like skin cancer
really easily so i've
been told to stay out of the sun but uh
it was um it was interesting i mean my
partner jimmy was i think more
surprised than i was
what was it like i mean you are one of
the characters that goes into this
as a couple so what was it like actually
having somebody
by your side to go through this with and
to have that
dynamic to explore yeah it was really it
was really interesting and i love
melvin you know we would get together
beforehand and sort of talk about these
scenes because the scenes were
really nuts and crazy and it was hard to
keep track of where our characters were
at each
time so it was really good to be able to
just have someone to whisper like okay
where are we in this one okay we've just
had
okay so we're here you know um
yeah it was good to have you know like a
a partner through it all and being able
to
explore not just what jessica's going
through but what jessica and ben are
going through as a couple as well
well i appreciate you talking to me
about it i had so much fun with your
character and getting to see you in a
row like this
so thank you